Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Es geht um den Aufbau von freier Informationsinfrastruktur, in diesem Fall von Funknetzen, in denen jeder, der Freifunk hat, nicht nur Teilnehmer, sondern Netzinfrastruktur ist.
Das heißt, man zieht das Wille ja nicht nur, sondern stellt es gleichzeitig auch noch für andere bereit. Wir haben jetzt im Laufe dieser Sendung schon geklärt, wo das herkommt, also geschichtlich, da ging es um Datenklots, dann haben wir geklärt, was man machen muss, um daran teilzunehmen. Es geht relativ einfach, wenn man einfach ins Netz will, wenn man knallt den Rechner auf und lockt sich ein und klickt eine Einverständniserklärung, dass man keinen Unsinn macht und wenn man selber das ganze Netz teilen will, also mit anderen auch mitteilen will, dann stellt man sich einen Router, der auf eine besondere Art und Weise behandelt wurde, ins Fenster. Das heißt, wir wissen jetzt schon im Kleinen, wie man das macht. Im Großen ist es ja so, aber auch so ein Freifunknetz muss irgendwo hinkommen. Da ist es gerade schön mit den Worten beschrieben, wie versorge ich ein Dorf mit Freifunk? Das ist ja auch ganz praktisch, wenn es da zum Beispiel hier in Brandenburg, nicht so selten leider, Orte gibt, wo es gar kein Netz gibt. Wie versorgt man denn jetzt so ein Dorf mit Freifunk?
Ja, es gibt eine ganze Menge Dörfer, die nicht ans Internet angebunden sind, zumindest nicht breitbandig. Das ist halt auch immer so eine Kostengeschichte. Und der Mensch ist ja nur wert, was man an ihm verdienen kann, zumindest wenn es um Internetversorgung geht. Und da sind halt ganz wenige Menschen und die sind ziemlich weit ab vom Schuss. Und das sind lange Kabel und viel Technik, die man da braucht. Und das ist natürlich viel schöner, in den Ballungsgebieten Netz anzubieten. Und was man da macht, ist Folgendes. Man tut sich zusammen und man sucht in der Nähe des Ortes, in dem man da wohnt, Internet. Das ist relativ einfach. Es gibt da diese Verfügbarkeitsprüfung. Und guckt mal in den Nachbardörfern und in den Nachbarstädten. Und früher oder später wird man feststellen, 8 Kilometer entfernt oder 7 Kilometer oder 12 Kilometer entfernt gibt es ja schon Internet. Da findet man dann meistens dann 4 MBit oder 6 MBit DSL. Das kann man auch relativ einfach machen. Es gibt da diese Verfügbarkeitsprüfung von diesen verschiedenen Anbietern. Die wollen immer, dass man eine Telefonnummer angibt. Deshalb sucht man sich auf die Telefonnummer der Dorfkneipen raus und gibt die da ein.
Jetzt wisst ihr, warum Kneipen ein Telefon haben. Nicht nur mal mit dem Würst namens Scherze zu treiben, nein. Auch damit ihr nachschlagen könnt, ob es dort Internet gibt.
Genau, und dann weißt du ziemlich schnell. Dann suchst du dir den höchsten Punkt im Dorf oder im Dorf näher raus. Das kann ein Kirchturm sein, das kann ein Getreidesilo sein. Das kann irgendetwas hohes sein. Du stellst dich da oben rauf und machst mal einen schicken Panoramachot. So richtig einmal mit der großen Spiegelreflex rumdrehen und kannst dann, das tust du bei klarem Wetter, einfach mal sehen, was man sieht.
Man muss das so sagen, so Kirchen sind prädestiniert dafür. Das sind grundsätzlich immer hohe Gebäude mit überwiegend freundlichen Leuten drin.
Ja und die haben auch noch Sendungsbewusstsein. Schon länger als das Freifunk. Und sie sind häufig auf Hügeln gebaut. Das kommt ja noch dazu. Sogar in Berlin. Und dann wirst du feststellen, das Dorf da hinten, da gibt es ja Netz und da gibt es auch einen hohen Punkt. So und dann gehst du da hinten und sprichst mal mit den Leuten, sagst du, ja wir machen hier gerade so eine Bürgerinitiative, wir wollen nämlich ans Internet und du hast da dieses schöne Gebäude, diesen Schornstein und wir würden gerne also bei dir einen DSL-Anschluss legen lassen und mal ein Kabel auf deinen Schornstein. Und dann sagt der Wut, was willst du denn? Dann sagt er, ja guck mal hier Freifunk, Richtfunk und so weiter und das tut gar nicht weh. Und jetzt kann man ungefähr drei Monate Kommunikation und interne Abstimmung überspringen und baut dann Geräte und zwar baut man an sein Kirchturmgerät oder an seinen Getreidesilo und das ist so eine Richtfunktechnik und dann baut man am anderen Ende ein Gerät und dann setzt man dort noch einen Router hin und dann hat man auch ohne Probleme über 8 km, über 12 km, wenn da kein Hügel zwischen ist, eine Funkverbindung.
Könnten wir noch ein bisschen genauer spezifizieren, was heißt ein Gerät an den Kirchturm bauen?
Ja, also noch vor drei Jahren war das alles furchtbar aufwendig und anstrengend. Da gibt es auch ganz ganz schicke Bilder unter Freifunknet. Da sieht man dann so Schaltkästen mit jede Menge Technik drin und Geräte und Antennenkabel und Anschlussadapter und so weiter. Inzwischen gibt es Unternehmen, die kleine praktische handliche Hardware für wenig Geld herstellen. Das heißt, man hat dann so eine Plastikbox, die hat so eine Aufnahme, damit man die mit zwei Kabelbindern an den Rohr oder an den Masten festmachen kann. Da steckt man noch ein Kabel rein. Das Strom kommt auch über dieses Kabel. Und da läuft, man glaubt es kaum, eine Freifunkfirmae drauf.
Und sozusagen so ein Plastorouter, nur genau für den Zweck optimiert, wo man halt eine Antenne dran hat, die entsprechend gerichteter ist. Also gerichtet, wenn man das halt gerade braucht. Früher musste man sich diese Antennen noch entweder ganz, ganz, ganz teuer kaufen oder aus Chips-Dosen selber bauen und dergleichen mehr. Und das war natürlich alles so ein bisschen Frickelkram, weil je günstiger man das haben möchte, je mehr man verbauen möchte, desto mehr leidet dann auch da die Qualität. Und wenn man jetzt einfach so sich das im Netz klicken kann für schmales Geld, dann hält das auch den nächsten Winter.
Also schmales Geld heißt in dem Fall was?
Deutlich unter 100 Euro pro Gerät. Also halt schon so im Segment, wo man auch gehobene Plastorouter finden würde.
Okay, und das ist die Antenne, die das Signal austrahlt?
Na, das ist schon gleich ein Access Point, wo halt so ein Linux drin läuft. Diese Freifunkfirmen wir auch mit einer eingebauten Antenne. Sprich, man hat dann auch gar kein Problem mit Kabeln und Kabelverlust. Und da gibt es auch nicht nur einen Hersteller, der das herstellt. Ich hab irgendwie gestern mal wieder umgeklickt. Also da gibt es ja mittlerweile einiges.
Es gibt da für 80 bis 100 Euro pro Ende Geräte und das ist alles schon fertig.
Also sowohl für das eine als auch für das andere Ende gibt es schon die fertigen Geräte. Das heißt, ich lege mir also sagen in dem Dorf, das schon Internet hat, nur ein kleines gallisches Dorf, das hat schon Internet. Und da baue ich diese eine Box ran und klick mir dann Internetanschluss für. Und der funk dann sozusagen direkt über, was ist die maximale Entfernung? Sind das diese 12 Kilometer, die du gerade genannt hast?
Ja, das ist eine Frage. Also es ist, wenn du hohe Türme hast, kannst du auch 20 Kilometer funken. Wenn du nicht so hohe Türme hast, kannst du 8 bis 12 Kilometer funken. Wenn du Hügel dazwischen hast, wird es schwieriger. Wenn du keine Hügel hast, einfacher. In Venezuela haben sie mal mit völlig übertriebenem Aufwand 240 Kilometer gefunkt.
Das ist dann aber nicht mehr für unter 100 Euro zu machen.
Das war eine 3-Meter-Satellitenschüssel oder sowas.
Wir merken uns sozusagen bei freier Sicht, 8 Kilometer kein Problem.
Kein Problem, 8 Kilometer.
Alles andere müsste man so experimentell machen.
Das war aber auch nicht immer so, dass man so wirklich große Distanzen überbrücken kann, weil dieser WLAN-Standard eine kleine Fiesheit hatte, die natürlich die Hersteller und gleich in meinem Spezifizieren als Stolperstein in den Weg gelegt haben. Das war diese Geschichte mit dem AX.
Ja, das gibt halt einen Zeitraum, wo die Bestätigung für das Paket kommen muss. Das sind ein paar Mikrosekunden und das Licht ist halt nicht so schnell. Deshalb war die Reichweite, wenn man sich an die Spezifikation gehalten hat, auf maximalen Kilometer begrenzt oder sowas.
Ach so, ich dachte ja, wie in diesen Plastokästen ist was anderes als WLAN, aber es ist tatsächlich einfach nur WLAN, was sozusagen gebündelt wird. Aber trotzdem habe ich am anderen Ende dann auch ein bestimmtes Gerät, was das empfängt und dann wieder weiter verteilt. Oder sozusagen einfach, ok.
Also heute sind das Geräte, die in 5, 8 Gigahertz Band funken. Es gibt ja so verschiedene Frequenzen und das, was du in deinem Notebook drin hast, kann wahrscheinlich beides, nämlich 2, 4 und 5 Gigahertz. Mein Notebook hier kann nur 2, 4 Gigahertz und die Geräte, die wir da verwenden, funken eigentlich alle bei 5 Gigahertz.
Anders als um das sogenannte ISM Band, also Industrial Standards and Magic oder so. Was ein freies Band ist, 2, 4 Gigahertz wurde da bewusst gewählt, weil das auch der Bereich ist in dem normale Mikrowellenöfen. Und das will man eh für Funk nicht so richtig und für zuhause geht das. Und der Ticke an dem 5 Gigahertz Band ist, dass man da eben nicht diese Mikrowellenöfen hat, sondern dass man das weitestgehend für sich alleine hat.
Also ich hab jetzt letztens bei einem WLAN-Scan auf einem 13 Geschösser oder so was mal ein anderes Netzwerk gesehen mit 5 Gigahertz. Das Band ist also so bei den Dächern Berlins noch frei. Wenn ich das mit 2, 4 Gigahertz mach, dann hab ich glaube ich in zwei Sekunden 300 bis 400 Exosyphons, die ich sehen kann. Also das ist frei dadurch, dass es eine andere Wellenlänge hat, für die Fresnelzone nicht so groß.
Und auch die Ausbreitung ist, also je höher so eine Frequenz ist, ist die Ausbreitung immer mehr wie Licht. Sprich so ein 2, 4 Gigahertz Netz geht natürlich eher durch Wände durch als 5 Gigahertz. Sieht man auch bei Mobiltelefonen, Nagezeitenetze, die 900 MHz funken und welche, die in 1, 8 Gigahertz funken. Und erstere kann man auch noch im Keller empfangen an die mit 1800 MHz nicht. Aber das hat sich jetzt eher angeglichen, weil sie da noch mal ein bisschen umverteilt haben und da sind neue Frequenzen dazugekommen. Aber das nur am Rande.
Okay, also ich habe jetzt diese beiden Plastikkästen, die es extra dafür gebaut zu kaufen gibt, unter 100 Euro pro Stück. Und habe also von einem Dorf, wo ich dann dieses L-Anschluss habe, das in mein anderes Dorf geschickt. Und da baue ich dann am Ende sozusagen einfach einen ganz normalen Netzverteilungsinfrastruktur dran. Also Router oder Kabel oder wie auch immer, um das in die einzelnen Häuser zu bekommen.
Ja, einen Kabel zu verlegen ist ein bisschen übertrieben, wenn man gerade über acht Kilometer gefunkt hat. Kann man auch buddeln. Ja, was man macht ist, man baut dann nochmal einfach drei Antennen mit Mesh-Routern dran, also wieder mit Freifunk-Routern dran und richtet die in die drei Richtungen oder vier. Kann man sich aussuchen, je nachdem wie viel man da macht. Und dann stellt sich jeder irgendwie so ein kleines Gerät aufs Dach oder ins Fenster oder wie auch immer. Und hat da wieder dieses klassische Mesh-Netz. Das heißt, wenn mein Nachbar den Kirchturm sehen kann und ich ihn nicht sehen kann, dann funke ich halt über meinen Nachbarn. Und dies haben tatsächlich Leute gemacht. Da gibt es, spontan fällt mir der Freifunk Gado ein, aber da gibt es eine ganze Menge Dörfer, die inzwischen nicht mehr nur ihr eigenes Dorf versorgen, sondern die haben inzwischen weitere Funkstrecken gebaut zu anderen Dörfern, die auch kein Internet haben und die sie über ihre Internetleitung auch noch mit versorgen. Das heißt, da entsteht wiederum sowas wie ein Mesh-Netzwerk, wo dann die einzelnen Dörfer quasi knoten sind.
Wie ist denn das jetzt? Also die eine Frage, die mir zu einfällt ist, ich habe diese lange Funkstrecke über diese acht Kilometer, ist die abhängig vom Wetter? Also kann man da irgendwie, wenn es neblig ist, ist die Verbindung nicht so gut oder ist das relativ stabil?
Das ist relativ stabil.
Und die andere ist, was ist denn die Mindestvoraussetzung für den Anschluss, den ich da haben muss, damit es irgendwie einigermaßen Netz für alle gibt?
Ja, einigermaßen Netz. Man muss sich immer mal vorstellen, das ist für mich ganz schwer vorstellbar, man sitzt da und Netz heißt irgendwie Modem oder ISDN. Da kommen 64 Kilobit durch. Und wenn nicht das Mündel kommen 128 durch. Das heißt, wenn in diesem Dorf ein 2 Mbit Anschluss ist, dann können sich den durchaus 20 Leute teilen. Das ist gar kein Thema, das können auch 40. Dann hat man zwar noch nicht YouTube, aber man hat zumindest schon mal Mail und man hat Mails lesen und Mails senden und Websurfen ohne dass irgendwie gleich alles im Schneckentempo läuft. Wenn ich jetzt 40 Leute habe, sind 6 Mbit natürlich besser. Aber über 6 Mbit kann man auch ohne Probleme 40 bis 60 Leute abfackeln. Über eine 16 Mbit kann man also in der Vergangenheit 250 bis 300 Blogger mit Internet versorgen. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das das Äquivalent zu irgendwie 5 Dörfern in Brandenburg ist.
Aber es ist schon sozusagen, also man soll einfach das Größte nehmen.
Man nimmt, was man kriegen kann.
Je größer hat, desto komfortabler.
Wenn man ein Mbit kriegt, dann nimmt man ein Mbit. Wenn man 16 kriegt, nimmt man 16.
All right, gut, wir haben jetzt hier Lutz. Der hat eine Frage zum Netzaufbau. Wollen wir ihn gleich mit reinnehmen? Du bist doch derselbe hier von vorhin, oder? Alles klar. Du hattest noch eine Frage zum Netzaufbau.
Genau. Mal angenommen, ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel eine 2 MB, also Megabyte-Leitung und will jetzt nicht an dieses Freifunknetz mit rankehren, also als Geber. Und will ich jetzt aber nicht die kompletten 2 MB geben, kann ich denn einstellen, dass jetzt zum Beispiel von meiner Internetverbindung 1, 5 oder 1 MB an diese Freifunk geht und das andere behalte ich selber?
Ja, das geht. Und zwar ist das der Menüpunkt Netzwerk Firewall QoS und da kannst du dann 1 MB einstellen und dann wird dein Router nur 1 MB abgeben.
Und dann wegen der Reichweite, ich wohne ja in Oranienburg zum Beispiel und da sind ja hohe Häuser und ich wohne jetzt nicht ganz so hoch, ich wohne da in einem Einfamilienhaus nah am Rande und ja, was wäre denn so eine, also ich kann mir jetzt keinen Turm leisten, dass ich da jetzt ihn hinbaue und dann jetzt noch ein paar...
Man muss Opfer bringen.
Denn ich kann mir jetzt vorstellen, wenn ich den jetzt aufstelle, dass der dieselbe Reichweite hat wie ein ganz normaler WLAN.
Ja, da besorgst du dir ein paar Spackschrauben und Dachlatten im Baumarkt und baust du einen Turm. Nein, generell kannst du oben an den Antennenmasten ran und kannst mal in die eine oder andere Richtung funken. Und damit kommst du schon ganz schön weit. Und wenn du ein Hindernis hast und das ein Wohnhaus ist, dann kannst du ja auch mal Zettel in den Briefkasten werfen oder an das schwarze Brett hängen und Mitstreiter suchen und dann hast du plötzlich jemand in einem höheren Haus, der macht mit. Und wenn der mitmacht, dann leitet er das ja schon wieder weiter, weil jeder der mitmacht, vergrößert das Netz ja.
Also wie ist das mit Repeatern zum Beispiel? Die vergrößern ja auch teilweise die Reichweite. Kann man da ein paar Repeater zwischenklemmen?
Jeder Freifunkrouter ist so was wie ein Repeater++ on steroids. Also Repeater sind ziemlich dumme Geräte, die einfach nur repeaten und die Freifunkrouter machen Repeater Deluxe. Und das Freifunknetz ist quasi ein Netz, was nur noch aus Repeatern besteht. Das heißt, wenn dein Kumpel in dem hohen Haus 300 Meter weiter, den du sehen kannst, so ein Ding aufstellt, dann ist der Repeater und du bist Repeater. Und der kann wieder einen Kumpel sehen, der den sieht. Und schon habt ihr ein Netz und könnt dort irgendwie Dinge drin machen.
Und wenn ich jetzt, also ich möchte jetzt da einen Teil nehmen und jetzt hol ich mir einen Router und schick euch den, dass ihr da die Firmware aufspielt und ja, und dann kriegt ihr ihn zurück sozusagen.
Das kannst du selber machen. Da kannst du im Router auf Firmware Update klicken und dann nimmst du nicht die Firmware vom Hersteller, sondern eine Freifunkfirmware.
Kann man sich die dann von der Hinterseite runterladen?
Ja, da gibt es dann auch eine Liste der unterstützten Hardware.
Die Reihenfolge ist die, erst auf die Webseite gehen, dann dort gucken, welche Router unterstützt werden, dann einen davon kaufen, den mit der Firmware bespielen und dann loslegen.
Gut, okay, super, dann werden mir die Fragen schon mal antwortet.
Alles klar, dann viel Spaß damit. Eine Sache, die mir jetzt aber noch auffällt, ist Lutzburg in Oranienburg, also am Rande von Berlin. Da gibt es ja wahrscheinlich Netz. Um das mal klarzumachen, wenn es in einer Gegend schon Netz gibt, also einfach quasi, für jeden verfügbar, dann ist es eher eine Sache für Idealisten, um dort nochmal Freifunk hinzulegen.
Na, man kann eine ganze Menge mit Freifunk machen. Also ich bekomme über Freifunk mein Internetzugang. Das ist irgendwie so meine Grundversorgung. Aber Kumpel von mir, der halt irgendwie drei Straßen weiter wohnt, ist halt DJ und hat eine ultrafette MP3-Sammlung. Und diese MP3-Sammlung hat er halt auf so einem kleinen Server. Und natürlich habe ich auf diesem Server einen Account und kann irgendwie die Musik abspielen. Der hat nämlich einen kleinen Streaming-Server und ich kann halt bei mir in der Küche sitzen und der streamt halt einfach über das Freifunknetz von dem Server meines Kumpels.
Musikstreamen vom anderen, ist das illegal?
Ja, aber selbstverständlich. Ich meine, wir sind persönlich bekannt. Da ist ein Passwort vor und es geht auch ohne. Und das ist die ganz normale Privatkopie. Wenn ich den jetzt nicht kennen würde oder der im Internet ist, dann wäre das ja offensichtlich illegal. Aber ich kenne den, wir sind gleich ein Piraten-Crew. Der hat das wahrscheinlich auch alles gekauft, weil der hat einfach Platten.
Er hat das natürlich alles gekauft. Ich möchte meine Frage noch mal dahingehend spezifizieren. Wenn ich in einem Gebiet wohne, wo Internet sehr gut verfügbar ist, macht das keinen Sinn, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen als Alleiniger Freifunker da anfange. Sondern dann ist es wirklich eine Sache, da suche ich mir ein paar Leute und baue dann nochmal ein Freifunknetz auf. Genau. Diese Netzverteilungsgeschichte ist dann eher sekundär, weil es gibt ja schon Internet.
Ja, es gibt ja auch nicht für jeden Internet. Das ist, wenn du jetzt so einen Schufa-Eintrag hast oder ein schlechtes sonstiges Scoring oder irgendwo gebrannt markt bist in dieser wunderschönen Katalysmuswelt, dann hast du nämlich tatsächlich...
Lass mich die Frage noch mal anders formulieren. Du würdest also sagen, wenn ich schon einen Internetanschluss habe, dann soll ich auch einen Freifunkrouter hinstellen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich möchte jetzt noch kurz vor den Nachrichten den Mic reinnehmen. Der hat nämlich selber schon mal Freifunk genutzt und will uns, glaube ich, seine Erfahrung mitteilen. Oder sehe ich das falsch, Mike?
Ja, so ähnlich. Genau. Ich wundere mich doch sehr, dass man hier in der multimedialen Mikropole Berlin sich mit solchen Themen auseinandersetzt. Denn ich habe so zwei, drei Jahre im tiefen Schwarzwald gewohnt, in so einem kleinen anderthalbtausend Seelendorf. Und es gab nichts, gar nichts sozusagen. Von daher war das die einzige Möglichkeit. Und jetzt nach ihnen, wo ich wieder ein Jahr lang hier in Berlin wohne, kriege ich langsam mit, aha, das hast du da genutzt. Das ist völlig geil. Ich habe irgendwann mal jemanden kennengelernt, der sagte, Mensch, da haben sich doch zwei, drei Leute im Dorf mal den Kopf drum gemacht. Wie macht man das eigentlich? Und das nächste größere Stadt, die älteste Stadt, war in Württemberg, fast so 12, 13 Kilometer entfernt. Und über sage und schreibe 56 Kilometer Richtungstrecke war dann diese Internetverbindung möglich.
Sportlich?
Ja, mit Bergen geht sowas, das ist großartig.
Ja, es war wirklich fantastisch. Aber bei schlechtem Wetter und vielen Blitzen und Stürmen, die nötige Pokersession war da oft unterbrochen.
Aber immerhin, es gab nichts. Wie habt ihr das finanziell geregelt?
Das war auch ein Thema, was mich mal interessieren würde. Freifunkmäßig habe ich jetzt immer so gehört, jeder schließt sich an. Da ist es irgendwie anders gelaufen. Also eine Firma hat sich da selbstständig gemacht und hat die Hardware angeboten. Und wir haben eine D-Link Modem gekauft, für 100 ungefähr, und mussten eine Antenne, die ungefähr 900 Euro wohl hätte kosten sollen, für ungefähr 20, 30 Euro, wenn ich mich nur noch mieten würde.
Für das ganze Dorf aber?
Nein, für einen Haushalt.
Okay, jeder musste einen Router kaufen und für 20 Euro pro Monat so ein Ding mieten?
Genau, es ist so eine kleine Antenne, die ist so groß wie eine Konfekt-Shuttle, kann man sagen. Bei mir war zum Beispiel dieser Fakt, dass ich den Wasserturm im Dorf nicht sehen konnte. Der Nachbar arbeitete ziemlich gut, also ging aus meinem Fenster raus, in sein Fenster rein und dann zum Wasserturm und dann auf die 54 Kilometer. Hat funktioniert. Ich hab's niemals gehört, dass es so was gibt. Der ACB-Funk hab ich damals auch gemacht, da waren noch die Packet-Leute alle da, wo es furchtbare Geräusche gab, aber es hat halt geklappt. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, es war schon irgendwo spektakulär. Allerdings war es teuer, muss ich echt sagen. Also ich hab dafür einen normalen DSL-Anschluss, so locker mal 80 Euro bezahlt im Monat.
Okay, das liegt aber an der Hand, dass sozusagen von der Firma organisiert wurde. Wenn das Ganze ein Privatprojekt gewesen wäre, wäre das natürlich anders.
Ja, in der Tat, auf jeden Fall. Deswegen wundert mich jetzt, dass es so, ja, frei zugänglich, sag ich mal, in Anführungsstrichen jetzt hier auch funktionieren sollte. Denn natürlich für uns damals die wesentlich bessere Variante gewesen, vor allem die günstigere Variante. Aber so hat man auch einen Techniker gehabt, der vorbeigekommen ist und den ganzen Krämpel alles installiert hat. Und es hat funktioniert.
Allerweise kombiniert man dann einfach beides, holt sich einmal so ein Ding und verteilt es dann einfach weiter.
So, das wäre natürlich, wenn man gewusst hätte, was es eigentlich ist.
Naja, beim nächsten Mal ein Schwarzfall ziehen, du bist auf jeden Fall schlauer. Aber wo wir jetzt gerade schon dabei sind, du bist jetzt wieder in Berlin, da hast du ja jetzt, und du hast jetzt die Sendung auch irgendwie gehört, wirst du dir jetzt auch einen Freifunkrouter ins Fenster stellen?
Also in der Tat, ja, was soll ich sagen, also von der Sache wollte ich gar kein Wissen, der das irgendwie brauchen würde. Jetzt gerade, bevor er mich reingenommen hat, kam ja eigentlich so die Möglichkeit, von wegen gut die Leute, die wegen Schufa oder Tempel da irgendwo nicht den Zugang haben, für die würde ich das natürlich sinnvoll finden und mich auch daran beteiligen, dann hätte ich gar kein Problem. Aber ansonsten wäre ich gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen, wer sowas hier hätte nötig oder brauchen würde, sage ich mal, weil eigentlich ist hier das Internet allgegenwärtig. Ich kann mich erinnern, wir waren im Sommer mal irgendwo mit einem Boot draußen gewesen, da nimmt man so ein kleines Netbook raus, hat UMTS, alles ist wunderbar. Also wer braucht das hier, sage ich mal.
Gut, aber so sagen, also irgendwie Netbook und UMTS, das haben ziemlich viele Leute, aber das ist schon auch ein gewisser finanzieller Aufwand. Du musst das Netbook gekauft haben, du musst ein Mobilfunkding ins haben, wo du wahrscheinlich entweder Multisim hast oder einen zweiten Anschluss und du musst diese Online-Cosmetale, das ist schon Luxus, möchte ich immer sagen.
Das ist auch schon mal eine Ecke schicker, wenn man irgendwie sein Notebook aufklappt und dann da Freifunk hat und nicht sich über diesen UMTS-Strohhalm retten muss, also die 5-Giga-Arbeit, die man da so hat oder weniger.
Also will sagen, es könnte schon Sinn machen.
Will sagen, finde ich eine sehr interessante Sache, weil ich mich mit befassen.
Alles klar, dann viel Spaß dabei. So, jetzt haben wir schon geklärt, wer Geschichte hat, wir haben die Technik im Kleinen, also quasi pro Mensch der Freifunk nutzen will, die Technik im Groß, nämlich wie versorge ich ein ganzes Boot, wollte ich keiner sagen, weil gerade auf dem See war ein ganzes Dorf mit...
Internet heißt das eben.
Ja, die Sendung ist nur zwei Stunden lang, aber trotzdem passiert es immer wieder, dass das Chaos zuschlägt. Ich habe für diesen Fall mal was vorbereitet. Hören Sie überhaupt noch zu?
Und das hört man.
Das muss auch mal gesagt werden. Wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde Chaos Radio. Jetzt machen wir erst mal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht es gleich weiter. Heute Chaos Radio mit mir, der ich hier Knöpfchen drücken und so ein bisschen rummoderieren darf und außerdem Nibla vom Chaos Computer Club. Tag nochmal und Alex von den Freifunkern. Es geht nämlich heute um Freifunk. Wir haben gerade, es gibt einen Chat zur Sendung im IRC und da hieß es gerade der MW hier, Chaos Computer Club und überhaupt Personalausweis neu müsste man da nicht mal. Und überhaupt, das gab es letztes Mal schon. Also wenn euch für das Für und Wider des Personalausweises interessiert, dann könnt ihr auf chaosradio.ccc.de gehen und dort den letzten Podcast vom letzten Chaos Radio runterladen.
Allerdings sei dazu gesagt, wer morgen noch nichts vorhat oder wem der alte Personalausweis wichtig ist und da keinen neuen elektronischen Personalausweis mit all seinen Problemen und potenziellen Unsicherheiten haben möchte, der sollte morgen schnurstracks ins Bürgeramt oder allgemein halt die Behörde gehen, wo man sich sowas abholen kann, ein Untermeldeamt und noch einen alten Personalausweis beantragen. Das geht nämlich nur noch morgen.
Und ich habe gehört, man soll, wenn man das machen will, tatsächlich ganz früh unterwegs sein, weil wohl viele Bürgeramte um elf schon zumachen wegen neuer Technik einrichten. Hätten wir das auch geklärt, hier aber Freifunk, Freifunk also ein, ach nö wir fragen Alex einfach wieder. Alex, was ist denn eigentlich Freifunk?
Freifunk ist ein Modelleisenbahnclub für Nerds, die keine Lust mehr haben, in Kellern Modelleisenbahnschienen aneinander zu machen und deshalb große Linkstrecken quer durch Berlin ziehen. Und das können die dann auf der Karte angucken, wie fett die Linien da sind.
Das Ganze wird nur gemacht, damit es auf der Karte geil fett aussieht. So, wir haben schon geklärt, wie man dazu gekommen ist, geschichtlich, wie man technisch dazu kommt. Also im Prinzip sendungsmäßig sind wir jetzt in der Situation, dass wir hier Freifunk am Start haben. Was kann ich denn jetzt damit machen?
Ja, unglaublich viel. Also technisch gesehen hast du ein... Hör ich mich krieg? Technisch gesehen hast du ein Intranet. Das heißt, du hast da ein Netzwerk, damit kommst du einmal ins Internet und du kannst mit anderen Teilnehmern dieses Netzwerks kommunizieren. Kommunikation kann ganz viel sein. Es kann sein, dass du jetzt im Hausprojekt wohnst und da ist eine Punkband und die hat einen Auftritt und dann kannst du das ins Freifunknetz streamen. Oder, das wurde glaube ich sogar schon gemacht, oder da gibt es einen Kirchturm und da gibt es ein Falkennest mit einem Turmfalken und dann kannst du da eine Webcam aufhängen und kannst diesem Falken beim Brüten zuhören. Das machen zum Beispiel die Kiezfunker. Die haben da halt einen Rechner hingestellt und eine Kamera hingemacht und das ist sowieso, die Technik muss funktionieren, weil wenn der Falk gebrütet, dann kann man da keine Antennen schrauben, aber dafür kann man dem Falken zusehen. Und haben die Falkencam, das geht einmal innerhalb des Freifunknetzes und das geht natürlich auch im Internet, weil das wird auch noch hochgeladen. Aber ist natürlich nicht so schick. Und jetzt weiß ich, in NRW sind ein paar Leute, die diese Idee, die ich auch schon lange propagiert habe, mal machen wollen, die wollen nämlich eine Linkstrecke zwischen der Kirche und dem Altenheim machen, um die Sonntagspredigt zu streamen. Auch mal eine Lösung. Dann haben wir natürlich irgendwie alle unsere kleinen FTP-Server, die wir zu Hause stehen haben. Kennt man ja, man guckt mal einen Film und man hat den Film auf der Platte, weil das ist die legale Kopie, die man sich da auf der Platte aufbewahrt. Und die möchte man natürlich im Freundeskreis tauschen. Die sogenannte Privatkopie im Freundeskreis. Und das kann man natürlich auch ganz gut über das Freifunknetz machen. Und wenn man sich natürlich die Mühe macht, diese schicke Outdoor-Hardware, von der wir eben gesprochen hatten, nicht über acht Kilometer, sondern nur über 300 Meter Funken zu lassen, dann kann man da ohne Probleme 50 bis 70 MBit und mehr durchkriegen. Und das ist ganz schön satt. Damit kann man nämlich den Film direkt aus der Nachbarschaft streamen.
Aber das heißt, man kann also innerhalb dieses Netzwerks relativ viel machen. Aber wie ist es denn jetzt mit dem Internet-TM? Also habe ich da einfach einen richtigen vollwertigen Internetanschluss, wo ich alles machen kann? Oder muss ich da schon Einschränkungen hinnehmen?
Ja, also ein bisschen ausholen. Bei deinem DSL-Provider gilt das Prinzip, you get what you pay for. Du kannst ja da den kleinen Anschluss holen. Da hast du zwei Mbit, kriegst ein bisschen Internet. Oder du holst dir VDSL und hast da irgendwie richtig viel Internet. Und bei Freifunk funktioniert das generell ganz ähnlich. Nur, dass du halt, dass die Währungseinheit, die du investierst, ist halt nicht eine monatliche Zahlung. Und das versackt dann irgendwo bei deinem Provider. Und der kauft sich davon Porsche. Sondern die Frage ist, wie viel Zeit und Hardware investierst du? Also wenn du dir deinen Router ins Fenster stellst, dann kriegst du ein bisschen Internet. Und vielleicht auch mal eine Unterbrechung. Und wenn du Glück hast, gibst YouTube in Flüssig. Und wenn du Pech hast, musst du halt mal auf Play drücken und auf Pause drücken und ne 5 Minuten warten. Und kannst es dann abspielen. Wenn du natürlich investierst und was ausgibst, ja, da waren wir, you get what you pay for, und sagst okay, ich kauf mir von Ubiquiti eine Nano Station, das ist halt so ein Plastorouter in Wettefest, und schraub mir den aufs Dach und red mit der Gegenstelle und der dreht seine Antenne noch ein bisschen, dann kriegst du plötzlich viel schnelleres Internet. Und das Ganze läuft viel flüssiger. Wenn du natürlich jetzt sagst, okay, guck mal hier lieber Nachbar, willst du deinen DSL-Anschluss nicht noch ein bisschen upgraden und ich geb dir noch mal einen 5er im Monat oder einen 10er im Monat dazu, das ist immer noch billiger als mir meinen eigenen zu holen, dann wird dein Internet noch schneller. Das heißt, die Frage ist eigentlich, wie sehr bringst du dich ein? Wenn du nur konsumierst und einfach nur deinen Router ins Fenster stellst, dann machst du das Netz ein bisschen besser und kriegst ein bisschen Netz. Wenn du die ultra geile Dachinstallation baust mit einem Schaltkasten und sieben Antennen in alle Richtungen der Welt und ein fetter Knoten bist, dann hast du natürlich eine bessere Anbindung an das restliche Netz. Was auch dort gilt, du entscheidest darüber, wie gut das Netz ist in Form von Engagement. Und manchmal hast du halt das Glück, dass du neben jemandem wohnst, der dieses Engagement treibt, wie zum Beispiel einen Nachbar, dann kriegst du auch so schnelles Netz.
Das heißt also, um das mal festzuhalten, es ist nicht so, wie jetzt vielleicht die, wie heißen die, die Parasiten der Gesellschaft, die jetzt denken, ha ha, kostenloses Internet für mich, das funktioniert nicht, sondern es ist schon ein Ding, das auch davon lebt, das auch wirklich jeder mitmacht. Und im Zweifelsfall, wenn man es sich leisten kann, auch sozusagen einen eigenen Internetanschluss haben und den dann auch damit reinwerfen. Wie ist es denn rechtlich gesehen? Das ist ja eine Frage, die schon aufgetaucht ist. Und wie gesagt, es gibt eine ganze Sendung, aber nur noch mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst. Ich habe jetzt einen Internetanschluss, mache bei diesem Freifunk mit. Irgendjemand macht darüber Unsinn, kann ich dann belangt werden?
Grundsätzlich ist das in dem Prozess der Klärung. Wir hatten dieses BGH-Urteil. Das BGH hat gesagt, also du kannst deinen Internetanschluss, also es hat ja noch von einem Accesspoint gesprochen, nicht einfach so betreiben. Du musst da Sicherungsmaßnahmen betreiben. Und die müssen auf dem Stand der Technik sein. Wenn du dein Gerät einrichtest, dann bist du nicht dazu verpflichtet, diese Sicherungsmaßnahmen fortlaufend zu verbessern. Das heißt, das, was du vor 5 Jahren eingestellt hast, wenn das damals Stand der Technik war, dann ist das in Ordnung. Der BGH hat da natürlich diese ganze WPA, WPA2-Nummer irgendwie gemeint. Das ist aber halt genau das, was wir nicht machen, nämlich Gartenzäune bauen. Wir wollen ja irgendwie eine große gemeinsame Wiese, auf der wir irgendwie miteinander und nicht viele kleine Zäune und jeder macht sein eigenes Ding. Aber auch schon vor dem BGH-Urteil und auch schon vor diesem Prozess haben wir uns natürlich überlegt, so Filesharing, BitTorrent, E-Dunkey und so weiter. Das kann man zwar auch für legale Inhalte benutzen, aber es gibt ja auch tatsächlich Leute, oder es gab Leute, die haben sich gedacht, hach, ich hab zwar DSL, aber wenn ich jetzt Filesharing mach, benutze ich doch das Freifunk, dann bin ich dafür nicht haftbar. Es ist noch asozialer, als irgendwie ohne DSL irgendwie Freifunk für Filesharing zu benutzen, ist sein eigenen DSL-Anschluss auszusparen, um zu hoffen, dass jemand anders dafür haftet. Daraufhin haben wir darum verschiedene Leute gesagt, ja so geht das aber nicht, und haben entsprechende Technik entwickelt. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt einen Internetanschluss hast und möchtest den zur Verfügung stellen, dann, der Lutz hat ja schon mal gefragt, kannst du auf der einen Seite schon mal einstellen, wie viel du davon zur Verfügung stellst? Und dann gibt es verschiedene Sorten von Peer-to-Peer-Blockern. Das heißt, es gibt da eine Software, und die guckt sich diese Pakete an, und die sagt dann ja, hm, guck mal hier, idanki, nicht so gut, das drossel ich jetzt mal auf ein Kilobit oder so. Und dann läuft das nicht. Und eine andere Software, das wird bei uns das Zappscript genannt, das zappt deinen Internetanschluss einfach und leitet dich auf eine Seite um, und da steht dann, du, du, du, das war wohl eine scheiß Idee, die du erhattest, wenn du hier auf OK klickst, hast du jetzt erstmal wieder eine Stunde Internet, aber schick mal eine Mail irgendwie und lass uns mal miteinander reden. Das ist das Zappscript, das hat auch der Fels Sven Ola gebaut. Und wir haben die Erfahrung gemacht, gerade in der Nähe von Jugendeinrichtungen, dass dieses Zappscript ein paar mal zuschlägt und dann alle gelernt haben, dass wenn sie irgendwie Mist machen, das Zappscript irgendwie ihnen auf die Finger klopft. Und haben halt in der Anfangsphase des Einsatzes noch ein paar Alarme gehabt, aber das ist dann auch ganz schnell zurückgegangen, weil dann auch jeder noch mal drüber reflektiert. Was mache ich hier eigentlich? Ich könnte irgendwie tatsächlich, vielleicht kriegt der andere ja Ärger und eigentlich will ich das ja gar nicht. Und eigentlich habe ich darüber gar nicht nachgedacht. Jetzt habe ich drüber nachgedacht und jetzt lasse ich das. Und wenn ich nicht drüber nachdenke, dann kriege ich halt weiter auf die Finger geklopft.
Das ist wie bei so verletzten Computern immer. Man muss sich halt vor Augen führen, dass am anderen Ende des Geräts nicht nur irgendwas sitzt, was irgendwie Textbuchstaben ausspuckt, sondern ein Mensch.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass das zwar ein lobuswerter Ansatz ist, aber dass man ja davon ausgehen muss, dass da trotzdem irgendwie ein paar Spacken draußen sind. Ist denn schon mal ein Freifunker verurteilt worden?
Verurteilt nicht. Es wird immer eingestellt. Weil die haben, glaube ich, auch gar keine Lust, das durchzufechten. Und dann kommt da ein Urteil raus, was ihnen nicht passt. Weil wenn du dem Richter sagst, guck mal hier, wir haben hier zwei ganz legitime Interessen. Das eine ist irgendwie das Interesse der Content-Mafia an ihrem geistigen Eigentum und das zu verwerten und das ist nach unserer Rechtslage legitim. Deshalb bezeichne ich das hier jetzt auch als legitim, auch wenn man darüber jetzt anderer Meinung sein kann. Auf der anderen Seite eine Gruppe von Menschen, die die digitale Spaltung überwinden will, die freien Zugang zu Wissen und Bildung für alle möchte und das realisiert, indem sie freie Informationsinfrastruktur betreibt. Und wenn die Content-Mafia jetzt 100 Prozent Recht kriegt, dann kann dieses Netz nicht mehr betrieben werden. Wenn dieses Netz vollständig frei und offen ist, dann können die Interessen der Content-Mafia nicht mehr geschützt werden. Das heißt, wir haben ja eine Rechtsgüterabwägung. Und am Ende dieser Abwägung steht mit ziemlicher Sicherheit, wie auch schon beim letzten BGH-Prozess, dass Maßnahmen zu ergreifen sind. Und genau das tun wir. Wir haben nämlich zwei Elemente. Das eine ist das Acceptklicken. Das ist nämlich Nutzungsbedingungen. Und diese wirst also tatsächlich darüber belehrt und du musst diesen Nutzungsbedingungen zustimmen. Und wenn du das gemacht hast, dann kannst du erst ins Netz. Und wenn du gegen die Nutzungsbedingungen verstößt, dann kann der Ablinkbetreiber erst mal nichts dafür. Und wir haben diese Peer-to-Peer-Blocker und dieses Zappscript, welche sehr wirksame technische Maßnahmen zu Verhinderung sind. Sie können es nicht zu 100 Prozent verhindern. Das heißt, vielleicht kannst du noch 50 Kilobyte von diesem Pfeil runterladen, bis du es aufgibst. Das heißt, du kannst immer noch in den Fischnetzen der Abmahnanwälte landen. Aber man kann nachweisen, dass das ein kleines Rinsel war, was dann...
Und man lässt sich selber auch sagen, was dagegen unternommen ist.
Genau, man hat eine Maßnahme ergriffen nach dem aktuellen Stand der Technik. Und hat es nicht einfach fahrlässig in Kauf genommen. Es gibt die Aktion Freifunk statt Angst. Die findet man auf dem Internet. Und da sind jede Menge Aktivisten und Juristen und so weiter, die sich da zusammengetan haben, um solche Fälle zu bearbeiten. Und es ist immer eine gute Sache, auch an die Freifunk statt Angst Geschichte zu spenden, um diese Sache zu unterstützen. Aber dort nimmt man sich dann solcher Fälle an. Und dann gibt es normalerweise die modifizierte Unterlassungserklärung. Und dann ist die Content Mafia auch ganz schnell wieder ruhig, weil sie festgestellt hat, die wären sicher. Nee, da kann man ja gar kein Geld verdienen. Da gibt es ja nur scheiß Presse. Und wir kriegen noch mehr aus dem Maul und lassen mal lieber. Also Verurteilung in dem Sinne gar nicht, sondern es wird eingestellt.
Eine spannende Sache, die mir gerade aufgefallen ist. Es gibt ja derzeit oder es gab sozusagen vor einiger Zeit, und es ist noch nicht ganz vorbei, die Diskussion um Netzneutralität, wo es ja genau darum geht, dass eigentlich sozusagen dieses wir gucken uns andere Leute Daten an, nicht gewollt ist. Da hast du gerade erzählt, dass genau das aber gemacht wird in den Routern, dass man nämlich die Daten anguckt und dann so guckt, wo die herkommen. Gibt es da so kleine Glaubenskriege? Also weil so Freifunker und sind ja auch eher in dieser Richtung, so freies Netz und so was unterwegs. Aber da scheint sich das ein bisschen zu widersprechen.
Man muss da zwei Dinge unterscheiden. Das eine ist der freie Transit im Freifunknetz. Da gilt das sogenannte Pico Peering Agreement. Das wurde damals bei dieser Consumnet in London Geschichte vor Ewigkeiten entwickelt. Das besagt, ich kann das natürlich jetzt nicht runterbeten, aber das besagt im wesentlichen Verkehr von deinen Nachbarn, sollst du frei durchleiten, du sollst dafür auch kein Geld nehmen und so weiter und so fort. Es sagt aber auch, du kannst zusätzliche Dienste anbieten, du darfst dafür auch Geld nehmen und diese Dienste kannst du unter eigenen Nutzungsbedingungen anbieten. Internet Uplink ist ein solcher Dienst. Das heißt, wir sagen klar, der Treffig im Netz muss, also innerhalb des Freifunknetzes muss vollständig diskriminierungsfrei sein. Wir würden das auch sehr, sehr, sehr gerne über die DSL Uplinks machen. Und wir machen das auch dort, wo wir es können. Das heißt, es gibt gewisse Uplinks, wo wir andere Schutzschirme gegen die Bösen haben. Da filtern wir nicht, aber wir haben leider keine Wahl. Es wird bestimmt auch wieder Thema werden in den nächsten Jahren, wie man das verbessern kann. Aber da muss man tatsächlich an der Gesetzeslage arbeiten. Da gibt es Urteile, da gibt es Gesetze, da gibt es unterschiedliche Auffassungen auch. Und ich denke, das sind politische Prozesse. Und solange sind wir leider dazu gezwungen.
Also dass ihr sozusagen gegen die ideale Netzneutralität, wenn ich das mal verstoße, ist im Prinzip eine pragmatische Lösung, um keinen Ärger zu kriegen. Aber ihr hättet lieber, dass es nicht so ist.
Selbstverständlich.
So, ich wage es kaum zu glauben, aber zwölf Minuten vor Mitternacht scheint mir, wir haben jetzt einen ziemlich guten Abriss gehabt über das, was Freifunk ist und was es kann. Was fehlt noch?
Ja, Freifunk.
Du würdest doch etwa sagen, dass wir sozusagen zwei Stunden, dass zwei Stunden genug sind für ein so umfangreiches und komplexes Thema.
Nein, wir haben es jetzt kurz angerissen. Was ganz interessant ist, ist, dass Freifunk tatsächlich Entwicklungsarbeit in Bereichen geleistet hat und da bessere Arbeit geleistet hat als Forschung und Technik und inzwischen die Forschung sich das ziemlich genau anguckt, was wir da machen.
Inwiefern?
Naja, es muss man sagen, dass diese Mesh-Netze und die waren eine Zeit lang für die Wissenschaftler ganz interessant und die haben dann ganz viele Papers geschrieben und Standards gemacht und wir haben die dann immer ausgelacht. Wie gesagt, ist ja schön, dass du da was simuliert hast, aber wir haben hier irgendwie 600 Knoten über Berlin und 450 Knoten über Leipzig.
Angeber.
Klappt alles nicht so, wie du das vorstellst und inzwischen bringen wir uns in die Standardisierungsprozesse mit ein, in die IETF, die Internet Engineering Task Force und bauen an den neuen Internetstandards mit, wo dann wieder ein paar Wissenschaftler sagen, ja, aber theoretisch sieht das so ganz gut aus und dann kommt so ein Programmierer und sagt, komm mal mit auf den Kirchturm hier. Genau. Wir haben hier 600 Knoten und guck dir mal den Kirchturm an und guck dir mal diese Topologie an und guck dir diese Interferenzen an und dann sagt er, ja, das sieht aber alles ganz anders aus als in meiner Simulation und das wiederum hat dazu geführt, dass sie jetzt überall auf der Welt anfangen, quasi Freifunknetze für Forschungszwecke zu bauen. Das fing an am MIT natürlich, die sind immer fünf Jahre vor allen, anders, aber das ist ja auch das MIT. Und die TU Berlin baut ein Testbett, die HU baut ein Testbett, die Beuth Hochschule hat eine Dachinstallation.
Aber machen die da bei euch mit oder bauen jetzt ihre eigenen Kram, der ja nicht kompatibel ist?
Unterschiedlich. Also die TU-Installation könnte man, glaube ich, mit drei Knopf drücken in ein Freifunknetz umwandeln, die kann aber grundsätzlich alles sprechen. Die HU-Leute machen Berlin Roof Net, das ist was, das kann man undocken. Insofern ist es kompatibel, aber es ist eine eigene Technologie und sowohl Fraunhofer als auch Beuth Hochschule betreiben Dachstandorte, die in das Freifunknetzwerk integriert sind. Und bei Fraunhofer sitzt dann auch wieder jemand, der sich damit beschäftigt, wie man diese Netze vielleicht praxisnah simulieren kann und betreibt da auch wieder Forschungsarbeit.
Und damit wir wieder beim Chaos, ja.
Wir sagen, um das nochmal abzuschließen und vor allen Dingen weiterzuführen für alle Leute, die jetzt diese zwei Stunden sich angetan haben und denken, hey, Freifunk, das ist cool, da will ich mitmachen. freifunk.net ist schon gefallen, das ist die Webseite, wo ihr unterwegs seid, wo man sich auch ziemlich viel anlesen kann. Wo kann man euch in Berlin treffen?
Also es gibt in Berlin, es gibt die SeaBase, die Raumstation unter Berlin. Ich glaube, die wurde hier schon häufiger erwähnt. Da treffen sich die Freifunker am Mittwoch. Dann gibt es am Donnerstag im Herbert das Freifunk Berlin Nordost Treffen. Es gibt am Montag im Platzhaus in Pregnant Hill den Kiezfunkertreff. Es gibt, glaube ich, noch ein Treff in Kreuzberg. Der Friedrichshainer ist ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Es gibt eine aktive Freifunk-Community im Sublab in Leipzig. Es gibt im Maschinenraum in Weimar eine aktive Community. Es gibt eigentlich in jeder größeren deutschen Stadt Freifunk-Communities. Das wird normalerweise auch unter freifunk.net irgendwo verlinkt. Es gibt das Wiki, das ist wiki.freifunk.net. Da gibt es noch unglaublich viel mehr Informationen, vollständig unaufbereitet und diskordisch im Chaos. Sehr zu empfehlen, wenn man sich mit Antennen bauen und Routergehäuse bauen beschäftigen will, ist auch wiki.leipzig.freifunk.net. Man merkt, Freifunk ist dezentral. Freifunk ist organisch. Freifunk lebt. Menschen machen etwas und dann ist das Freifunk. Es gibt keine Freifunkbehörde. Es gibt auch keine zentrale Freifunkautorität. Es ist einfach dezentrales Chaos.
Aber trotzdem vielleicht nochmal für die Brandenburger, die jetzt denken, mein Dorf, wir haben einen Kirchturm, aber sonst noch kein Internet. Irgendjemand, an dem man sich am besten, also jemand, der sie vielleicht als besonders geeignet, als Ansprechpartner herausgestellt hat?
Also es ist hilfreich, sich auf der Freifunknet Mailingliste auf der WLAN-Werten zu melden und zu fragen, ob jemand in der Nähe wohnt. Die Berliner Mailingliste hilft auch. Wenn man die Freifunk Potsdam Leute kann man erreichen. Man kann auch einfach mal in der C-Base aufschlagen, sich vorher anmelden über die Liste und dann persönliche Kontakte herstellen. Normalerweise bildet sich dann ganz schnell, es kommt ja häufiger vor, dass Leute aus Gemeinden kommen und sagen, wir wollen das jetzt auch machen, dann bildet sich ziemlich schnell ein Kreis von unterschiedlichen Leuten aus den unterschiedlichen Fachbereichen und da wird Networking gemacht, da werden Kontakte geknüpft und dann kriegen die die nötige Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe, die Dokumentation, die Information und wo kriegt man die Technik und welche Fehler sollte man vermeiden und also das klappt eigentlich auch relativ gut. Mailing-Liste anmelden, sagen hey Leute, irgendwie gibt's mal einen Kontakt bei mir in der Gegend und dann wird der Kontakt meist recht schnell hergestellt.
Wo geht Freifunk hin? Also irgendwie, das hört sich ja alles ganz grov an. Ihr habt irgendwie so eine funktionierende Community am Start. Technisch ist es mittlerweile so weit, dass man es auch jemanden zumuten kann, der nicht mit einem Lötkolben umgeht. Gibt es da jetzt noch Weiterentwicklung? Oder irgendwo wo du sagst, das ist ein Meilenstein in der Zukunft, der noch bevorsteht uns?
Also natürlich mehr mehr, mehr Brandbreite, mehr Nodes. Aber was halt auch so Themen sind, ist Durchsuchbarkeit und Inhalte im Netz. Da ist schon angefangen, meine ganzen E-Books liegen im Netz. Das sind natürlich alles nur legale Scans von Büchern, die ich besitze. Und wie finde ich die Inhalte von den anderen? Wie publiziere ich Inhalte? Also was ich zum Beispiel gerne hätte, wäre so eine kleine Box mit Mikrofon dran und wo man noch einen Schalter umlegt und dann streamt das Ding, damit man einfach mal ganz einfach Konzerte und Predigten ins Netz streamen kann. Also viel mehr noch was passiert, weil wir haben halt wie gesagt die Content Mafia und die Abmahn-Anwälte und es gibt viele Dinge, die man viel besser in der Nachbarschaft machen kann. Also die interne Kommunikation. Technisch haben wir 802.11n mit Antennagrids und Beamforming und dann gibt es wiederum Mittel und Methoden, die erforscht werden, wie man die zentrale Synchronisation in verteilten Systemen erreichen kann, um dann halt den geeigneten Platz im Raum-Zeit-Continuum für sein Datenpaket zu finden, ohne dass dieses mit anderen kollidiert. Das ist alles irgendwie noch Rocket Science, aber wir partizipieren in der Firmenentwicklung, in der WLAN-Treiberentwicklung. Das heißt, inzwischen fressen wir nicht nur was hinten überfällt, sondern wir gestalten mit. Ich glaube, das wird in Zukunft noch viel mehr werden. Nämlich einfach neue Technologien mitgestalten und diese umzusetzen und auch irgendwie auf die Dächer zu bringen.
Also falls ihr jetzt einer von den wirklichen Hackern seid und gerade gesagt habt, oh Gott, Freifunk, da kann man sich noch Plastikkisten hinstellen, wo schon alles fertig ist, weit gefehlt. Ihr könnt auch richtig damit rumbasteln und sagen, an der Grenze zum Neuen forschen. Vielen Dank Alex von den Freifunkern.
Jetzt noch eine letzte Nachricht. Das wichtigste vergessen. IPv6 natürlich. Das neue Internet der nächsten Generation, unsere neuen Firmen, sind alle IPv6-fähig. Wir haben auch noch intelligente Mechanismen entwickelt, um das Alte mit dem Neuen migrationsmäßig zu machen. Und das ist eigentlich der Bereich, wo ganz, ganz viel passiert, weil unsere IP-Adressen werden noch ungefähr 240 Tage halten und dann gibt es keine neuen IPv4-Adressen mehr. Und spätestens dann muss das funktionieren. Da arbeiten auch wieder ganz viele Leute und da sind auch noch ganz viele ungelöste Probleme, wo es durchaus Fame gibt, im Form von Papers zu schreiben, RFCs zu schreiben und Referenzimplementationen zu machen.
Alles klar. freifunk.net ist die Adresse, wo ihr auch das nachschlagen könnt. Jetzt aber wirklich vielen Dank, Alex, fürs Vorbeikommen und das Erklären, was Freifunk eigentlich ist. Vielen Dank auch Nibbler vom CCC, der den Alex hierher geschleppt hat und Unterstützung gegeben hat. Viel Spaß euch. Ihr könnt euch, wenn ihr das alles noch einmal hören wollt, als Podcast runterladen, dürfte in ungefähr einer Stunde online sein. Was gibt es noch zu sagen? chaosradio.ccc.de, dort gibt es das, oder fritz.de. Hier kommt jetzt der Night Flight mit Florian Heiler. Wenn ihr wollt, hören wir uns im nächsten Monat wieder. Und Nibbler hat noch die Famous Last Words.
Nicht vergessen, morgen ist der letzte Tag für den alten Personalausweis.
Bis 11 Uhr, dann sollen angeblich die Bürgerämter zumachen. Ich sage noch, macht immer schon eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen und damit raus.